alright is this loud enough for
everybody or you get ready to shout it
at about Hadoop and not Hadoop okay cool
it's according to my internal clock this
is like nap time for me might be for
some of you after lunch so I'm gonna try
my best to make this fun and
entertaining and there's some terrible
puns in here so that if you're falling
asleep you'll have no choice but to wake
up and tell me how terrible they are so
all the slides for this talk I just
posted on Twitter I'm at me boy cos and
this talk is about me talking you down
from the ledge of distributed systems
and back into the safety of your local
machine so just a little bit about me I
work as a consultant at cap tech we do
IT consulting I work specifically in
data science and engineering so I do a
lot of projects around data movement
into distributed systems and as I've
been working on that I've noticed that
there are some pain points that working
on not distributed systems can solve if
you use them correctly so that's what
the talk is about personally I primarily
work a lot with spark Python sequel
stack overflow command-line that's my
main stack and I'm also on github
Twitter if you wanted me send me jokes
about how terrible my puns are okay so
we're gonna talk about how your computer
is good enough to do a lot of data
processing that you're thinking about
doing weather to decide whether you
actually have big data so you can make a
leap to a distributed platform and then
we're gonna talk about module and Python
called multi processing that can make
stuff faster so if you just saw the desk
presentation that Matthew Rocklin gave
he gave like the BMW of distributed
systems local processing we're gonna
scale it back this is like the Civic the
Honda Civic of multi processing on your
laptop and then we'll talk a little bit
if we have time about when you actually
do need distributed systems and what
they make sense for so okay so the birds
you know to everything turn turn there's
this season there's a time for
distributed systems and there's a time
for local processing and as a data
person or developer it's your
responsibility to
understand when you need to use one or
the other and come to that place of
healing away from the big data system
pain so we're gonna be working on my
local environment I just have a 2015
MacBook Pro nothing special it has a
quad core processor and 16 gigs of RAM
and that's going to become important
because the cores tell you how much
processing you can actually do so quad
core units you have one CPU and four
cores which you can run for processes
truly in parallel at the same time so if
you're trying to do processing you're
bound by what's available to you I
noticed a lot of people have math books
here if even if you have a Windows
machine or Linux and a similar
environment you'll probably be able to
get the same kinds of benchmarks that I
am on any kind of modern machine so
let's say that your boss comes to you
and he or she says please analyze lame
MapReduce for me so this is obviously a
pond on one of my favorite musicals lame
is Rob and I did not pick this only
because it is the best musical of all
time I also picked it because it's a
pretty big data file so one copy of lame
is Rob is like the third or fourth
largest novel in the English language so
it's about six hundred thousand six
hundred thousand seven hundred thousand
words or three point two Meg's for a
single copy of this program so your boss
says you comes to you in size I want you
to count the words in lame is Rob and I
want you to do a word frequency chart so
of course MapReduce the most common
programming paradigm in distributed
systems but the thing is you don't
always have big data you don't always
have to go to the cloud so there was a
website which no longer exists
unfortunately called your data fits in
rom-com
and you could basically go there and put
in how much data you had and it would
compare that against the size of like a
pretty big Dell server that you could
run on a single machine and it would say
you don't need distributed systems you
can do all your processing on this
single server so in working with data
across different companies I found that
there's like a sweet spot to how much
data needs to be processed so if you're
talking about kilobytes or megabytes
like we have in our single layman's are
on file you can probably even process it
I hate to say this using Excel so Excel
is actually in defense of Excel it's a
pretty good processor and it can process
up to two gigs of RAM
which means it compresses about a
million rows and I think if you have a
64-bit Excel it can actually do even
more once you get past that it starts
crashed and you start hating your life
so then you probably want to move on to
the the Pythons stack so you could write
your own Python code from scratch which
is what we're going to be doing or you
could go to Python or two pandas
processing chunks or you could even put
your data locally in the database like
Postgres or you could do command line
operations so up to about a gig or two
of data you can do all of this
comfortably using these tools without
ever leaving your local environment once
you get to kind of the ten gigs of data
50 gigs of data 100 you probably want to
start considering distributed systems
like spark like Hadoop like Postgres on
a server somewhere like doing something
in a cloud and then once you get past a
hundred gigs to a terabyte in a petabyte
then you really do need distributed
systems and the other thing to think
about is how fast all right so the
volume variety and velocity of data how
how often are you having to process this
data do you have a terabyte that you
need to process once
do you have gigabytes that you need to
process time and time again as the
architect or the data person that's
going to be your job to kind of look at
this scale and figure out what the right
tool for the job is so how much data can
your laptop process locally so data
brick is the company behind SPARC I did
some optimizations to the SPARC engine
this was a blog post from last
and they basically optimize it to the
point where you could do a billion
records joins and aggregations in the
second on a single 2013 MacBook Pro now
they are a vendor so it's their job to
tell you how awesome they're so take it
with a grain of salt but if they can do
even a fraction of that that's pretty
awesome on a local machine and then
there was also a really good blog post a
couple years back the link is on Twitter
I posted the slides where someone
processed basically two gigs of data
with two million chess games and they
used the find X orgs mock so each UNIX
command-line utilities pipeline and they
were able to do it in 12 seconds which
was 235 times faster than the same
Hadoop the mutation of that problem so
it really depends on your tool set of
what you have available and the data so
you could potentially process a lot on
your laptop if you optimize that process
so let's look at our file back to late
miss just do head on it just basic let's
start with command line so if we really
wanted to this is a pretty small file so
we could do a command line Map Reduce
so again so we have a pipeline where we
process the data clean it up and then we
group it together so the first part the
first couple lives said is a text
utility in UNIX it takes in the layers
or alt text file it gets all the
alphanumeric characters it strips out
the line breaks and spaces it compresses
the adjacent spacing it converts
everything to lowercase so that we can
count all words the same way it sorts
the words alphabetically and then the
you each see is what really does the
MapReduce work it counts the number of
unique occurrences and then we can pipe
that into a way to show this so you can
see that we get our word count for the
one file so we have Mario's who's a main
and then John John Valjean is part of
the main character so you can see their
names come up and then you get your
token words which you would probably
parse out so just look a sanity check
they are the main character so they
didn't hear the most often so this seems
pretty reasonable and so you here you
have your word count and just like a
single command line change okay so what
if we have more than one lame azeroth
file so let's say we have a thousand of
these files and so this is just a small
batch script to basically replicate that
file a thousand times
so the original file size is 3.2 3.3
Meg's and after we did that replication
we came out to 3.2 gigs which is now
getting into medium data size which is
probably more than you want to process
using a command line operation so now we
can actually get to writing some Python
so with command line it's fantastic it's
great it's really good for one-off tasks
you can't really see what's going on
under the covers and also Python is
awesome so now we're gonna rewrite it
we're gonna reimplemented in python from
scratch so what we have a script called
Map Reduce at PI and what that's gonna
do is the same kind of operations that
unix commands did so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna get our text input we're
gonna clean it up a little bit we're
gonna process it we're gonna add it all
together we can count the occurrences in
each file and then we're gonna aggregate
all those files so it's almost the same
as we had before we're just adding this
reduce function so again so we have a
function called get filenames it's going
to get all our text files get data is
going to do the text processing and
strip and split and all that stuff the
map function is going to count the
occurrences of unique occurrences of
words in each file and the reduced
function is going to sum up all that
stuff across the files and then show
items is going to spit that out and all
this code is available in my github repo
as we said before we kind of skipped the
non-glamorous part of text processing
which is like 80 to 90% of our daily
work just so it looks good in a press
so here is act the actual I did want to
show the map and reduce so what we have
here is some map it's gonna take a
single file name so it's gonna it's one
process it's gonna take a list of words
in that file and it's gonna try to add
them to a dictionary and if it doesn't
exist it's gonna add them so it's gonna
increment a counter and then with the
reduce it's gonna take a list of
dictionaries because we now have
multiple math processes so we need to
kind of group them all together it's
gonna iterate through that list and then
through all of those dictionaries and
then try to append to another dictionary
if that file if that word exists and if
it doesn't add it so that is essentially
the entirety of MapReduce and that is
what Big Data has been based on for the
last five years so now you know the
entire secret and you can implement this
from scratch and if you kind of look at
the reduce function you can also do
collections counter that's an even
easier way to implement it I just wanted
to show how you actually do the
mechanics of it so here's what we have
passed in the map so each again each
file produces a dictionary so we have
account for each file and then the
reduce is gonna add up those counts
across the file so you get a complete
list of all of your words
so how long does it take to run this
process so here's here's the code that
you would use to run it in non paralyzed
non optimized way you would loop through
the filenames you would put them into
the map function you would append them
and then you would do the reduce
function on that list so this function
with about 3.1 3.2 gigs takes about 5 5
minutes 14 seconds time is a really
nifty function that I learned about
recently it's really cool yeah so that
takes about 5 minutes
a little over 5 minutes so how can we
speed this up let's say because it's
gonna grow exponentially right if we
have 5 gigs of files or 10 gigs of files
it's going to take exponentially a
longer time so the way to do this is
multi processing and then on top of that
we can do pi PI so in order to
understand how multi processing works we
need to understand a little bit about
threads and processes and Gil so the way
that Python works is it can run a single
process or it can run it's bound by a
single thread by single process so
process is a program so if you think of
a process as running a word document or
running Excel or running a notebook
write a Jupiter notebook those are all
examples of processes in our case a
process is the MapReduce program itself
and then a process has sub processes
that it runs so a sub process is a
thread it's called a thread and so our
sub processes are all the functions that
we mapped out so get file names get Data
Map Reduce and then show items each of
those is a thread and the way that
Python was architected in the beginning
was it has a global interpreter lock
which means it can only run one thread
per process so you can only do one thing
at a time so in this case so the snakes
are like blocking
other processes imagine that so you have
get filenames which starts to run and
you can't run anything else which means
it's really slow because we potentially
could run map in parallel right we could
count the number of words per file and
we could do that for each file
simultaneously like we're not bound by
any other process there so that is
slowing us down that's why it makes it
five minutes and so if you look if you
run Python MapReduce that PI and you run
the top command which shows you what's
actually going on as you run stuff you
can see that it's utilizing 99% of a CPU
so in this case that's one core and then
the hashtag or pound th is the number of
threads running so this is what Python
limits youto so you can see that there's
only one processor running which is
really gonna slow us down so the way to
solve this is we can use something
really cool called a multi processing
API which allows you to treat each
function call as a separate process so
you could potentially run tens or
hundreds of processes at a time so
there's two to two things that you can
use in a multi processing API you can
use process which is pretty easy because
you don't have to specify anything so if
you use process basically processes and
control and it'll spin up however many
processes it deems necessary so it's
good for really small things it's
probably not good if you're trying to
process a thousand files because then
you're just gonna like crash your
computer and then there's pool which
allows you to control the number of
processes that you have going on it also
allows you to control the size of the
chunks that you pass into the processes
there's also map async which we're not
going to get into because that gets a
little more complicated but basically
the map function within pool is what
we're going to be using because it's
similar to what we've been doing and map
is a good paradigm to a parallel process
a lot of data
so here is what map actually takes so it
takes a function it takes an iterable
and you can specify a chunk size if you
want so the way this works so for ours
what we're doing is so we're still
getting the filenames the bottom here
first then we're saying that we let's
say we want to do five processes at a
time we're going to pass in our map
function to pool because that's what we
want a parallel process and then our
iterable is the number of files so we
want to map over all our files in chunks
instead of having to do it one by one
and we set the chunk size to 30 and I
predetermined that this was a good size
but you will probably want to play
around with it with your code to see
what gives you the best performance so
you're splitting this up into five
processes and so each of those has a
chunk size of 30 so each process is
running 30 files through the map
function at the same time and then it's
starting again so you're really
splitting up and paralyzing your tasks
and then we run everything through the
reduced function and then when we were
on top then you can see that you
actually have five pythons so it's
simulating five pythons that are still
each at a single thread but now you can
run five of them at the same time to
speed up performance
so how long does this take this cuts us
down to a little bit under three minutes
and you can see that we get the same
results so if you think about we had
like a thousand so this is times a
thousand so now we're getting all that
same data back and we just shaved two
minutes off of our five minute job
without I need optimizations off the bat
so the other thing you can do is if you
want it to go really fast its butyl
endorsed is to use pi pi which is an
alternate processor so R an alternate
interpreter so Python uses C Python you
can use pi pi instead and it does some
optimizations under the covers the
trade-off here is if you're like well if
it's so fast why can't I just use it for
everything and just use it all the time
because it takes a while to set up
because it's setting up those
optimizations so you want it to run
mostly Python processes and on mostly
Python code bases so like if you have a
seat
mostly C code base it won't optimize for
that as well and so if we run it through
pi pi it takes even less time it takes
two minutes ten seconds and then let's
say we have double the size of files
let's say we have six gigs that we want
to process that entire process takes
four minutes and 23 seconds with both
the multi processing and the pi PI
whereas before oh and I just ran it
straight through unoptimized I had to
stop after 13 minutes because I was
really worried about my computer span so
this is fantastic way to process data if
it fits into what you're doing so again
so you can process fairly large amounts
of data five to ten gigs easily locally
using multi processing make sure that
your code is structured for it so our
map function was really good because we
needed to do a bunch of stuff at the
same time like we didn't need to wait
for other processes to finish in which
case you would probably move into async
IO territory and then you can also try
different pool chunk size process
optimizations and then if
you really want to speed it up you might
want to consider moving to pi pi which
would make it even faster so that was
walking me through how things work
locally so the whole point is that when
you're thinking about a distributed
system all the stuff that we talked
about like setting the bucket size the
chunk size rewriting the code to be make
sure that it was paralyzed about all
that stuff happens in distributed
systems but it takes much longer and it
takes much longer to start them up and
so there's a really good paper about how
an optimized single node a K your
machine is better than multiple nodes
and so you could also do this using
spark locally and it takes much less
code but what you're doing so in a
distributed system so I just walked you
through how the process works for Python
in a distributed system what you're
setting up for example in spark is you
have the spark contacts then you have
drivers that you have executor so you
have a bunch of different things that
are listening to each other and waiting
for different aspects to finish which is
where a lot of the overhead comes in
so the code takes much less to write so
I think my code was like a hundred ten
lines or something for MapReduce you
could probably reduce you to even
further this code takes much less time
to write but it takes much longer to run
so I think for so for this one it took
about ten minutes to run with spark
locally so again so what Big Data can't
give you when you're thinking about
moving to a big data system is any kind
of consistency guarantees data integrity
all that stuff but what it can give you
so I talked a lot about what we can do
locally what it can give you is if
you're thinking about moving is a lot of
storage of unstructured data so again up
to that so ten gigs and more range fault
tolerance and availability if your
single node machine goes down and you
have stuff process on your laptop like
that's it you're gonna lose it if you're
working with a lot of other team members
it's a centralized place to store stuff
and it really gives you performance
improvements up
that 10-gig mark so those are just some
things to think about let's see I am
actually early so I will give you back
some time and I'm gonna stop there and
pause for questions what do you mean
yeah for pandas you could potentially
fit a lot because pandas also allows you
to chunk data so I think I've done I
don't know the largest I've done is I
think I've done maybe up to like five
gigs in pandas but I know people have
done much more but it becomes a little
bit unwieldy like once you really start
to get out there
yep so how would you say
see multi-processing and high-five
nurses
running a single script and then using
something like like new parallel I don't
know that's a good question I haven't
used that but that could be something
you could explore and write a blog post
about lightning talk yeah
okay cool
[Music]
you
[Applause]